what may come as a shock to some
but not others
is new testimony from dr deborah burks
remember dr burke's prominent figure
early in the pandemic response under the
trump administration dr deborah burks
now says
the trump administration
could have prevented
30 to 40 percent of covet deaths had
trump taken different actions and taken
the pandemic more
seriously newsweek report burke's
estimates trump administration could
have prevented could
30 to 40 percent of covet deaths the
trump administration's former
coronavirus adviser dr debra burks
estimated that thirty to forty percent
of the seven hundred thirty eight
thousand coved 19 deaths in the u.s
could have been prevented had the white
house taken necessary steps to curb the
spread of the virus in a closed-door
testimony conducted by the house select
coronavirus subcommittee on october 12
and 13 berks testified that more than
130 000 american lives could have been
saved
in the administ if the administration
promoted mask wearing and social
distancing in the early days of the
pandemic
according to excerpts shared by the
committee burke said i believe if we had
fully implemented the mass mandates the
reduction in indoor dining the getting
friends and family to understand the
risk of gathering in private homes and
we had increased testing that we
probably could have decreased fatalities
into the 30 percent less to 40 percent
less range asked whether former
president donald trump did everything he
could have to handle the pandemic burke
said no and i've said that to the white
house in general and i believe i was
very clear to the president in specifics
of what i needed him to do
we suspected this
but we didn't exactly know how to
quantify it we knew
of course we would have had deaths
regardless all countries have had them
but we suspected the numbers would have
been lower had trump taken this
seriously when trump was saying we have
15 cases which will soon be zero i mean
at this point a globally humiliating
statement to have made
if he had been doing something instead
of downplaying it we knew the death
count would have been lower we just
didn't know how much lower the u.s
postal service had a plan to mail out
masks to everybody and it got shot down
all in the name of slowing down the
postal service for the election and in
not making it seem as though this was
really a problem and then of course you
had the falsehoods and you had the
misinformation spread during 2020. those
to this day are killing people
people who because of the disinformation
refused to wear masks people who because
of the disinformation refused to get
themselves vaccinated um another report
on this in a business insider
trump's white house ignored advice on
covid that could have saved over 130 000
lives burke said um burke's testified
that the 2020 election
distracted trump from the pandemic so is
it good that dr burks is saying this
yeah i guess it's good
was she a purveyor of disinformation
during her time as coronavirus advisor
absolutely and we can go back and forth
and say well she was in a really tough
position or she may have calculated i
need to stay because if i leave
this gets even worse but remember that
completely
bizarre interview where she said donald
trump is just amazing at
paying attention to the facts and making
decisions on that basis on covet and we
looked at it and we said what the hell
is he talking about here what what on
earth is this this doesn't make any
sense whatsoever
uh and yet she continued to insist no no
no he's do now okay
later
it was intimated it was said it was
suggested man you know she was in a
delicate situation there was only so
much he could said but i mean you guys
remember this stuff right
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
uh by
injection inside supposing you brought
the light inside the body right you guys
remember all that stuff and dr burke's i
mean okay she looked confused but she
continued to run interference for that
administration until it was too late so
great she lets us know that we were
right in what we suspected trump not
only could have prevented 30 to 40
percent of deaths by the way he could
have easily sailed to re-election by
doing it as i've said many times before
kovid was a major drag on trump's
re-election which ultimately didn't
happen and he lost he lost badly in the
popular vote to joe biden but it was
only a few hundred thousand votes in a
few states that electorally handed
donald trump a defeat if from day one
trump had simply said we are gonna we
are really gonna take this as seriously
as anyone
listen to these doctors
wear your masks we've got trump masks
it's so stupid but if he had done that
right away
uh he would have sailed to reelection
and we would have saved many many people
so dr burke certainly deserves criticism
as we've said before
uh but there is no question that not
only could trump have saved people he
could be president right now if he had
better handled it let me know your
thoughts we're going to have more
coverage of this on the david pakman
show instagram make sure you're
following us there at david pakman show
you can follow me on instagram at
david.pakman
we will get to the latest on the january
6th committee
after this short break one of our
sponsors is blinkist who's been
supporting the david pakman show longer
than any other sponsor blinkist is the
app that lets you listen to or read an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below